karl es un experto en vida silvestre y
su tarea más reciente es mantener un
registro de la población de coyotes en
lyton town donde apareció recientemente
un tornado desde el tornado karl ha
documentado el tamaño de la población de
coyotes en relación a cuántos meses han
transcurrido desde el tornado trazo de
los puntos en la gráfica que se muestra
abajo así que vamos a ver de una vez
aquí tengo los coyotes y por acá tengo
los meses y un montón de puntos y dos
curvas estas dos curvas lo que intentan
es ajustarse a los puntos que tenemos
aquí y de hecho es justo lo que vamos a
hacer pero antes de eso quiero que te
des cuenta de algo estos puntos
representan los datos que tomo cal en su
registro
por ejemplo este de aquí representa que
uno dos tres meses y un cachito más tal
vez sean tres meses y una semana cuando
tomo este registro tres meses y una
semana después se dio cuenta que había
440 colores aproximadamente por ejemplo
este otro de aquí lo que dice es que
hizo una medición 12 dos meses y medio
después del tornado un poquito más y
obtuvo el valor de bueno cerca de 510
coyotes así que aquí lo tenemos de hecho
dicen desde el tornado karl ha
documentado el tamaño de la población de
coyotes en relación a cuántos meses han
transcurrido desde el tornado tras los
puntos en la gráfica que se muestra
abajo justo lo que vimos está buscando
una función que modele sus datos como la
tendencia de los datos es decreciente y
cóncava y te puedes dar cuenta de eso
justo acá abajo estos puntos tienen una
forma de una función que va decreciendo
los puntos van decreciendo a lo largo de
los meses y además tiene una forma
cóncava es decir hacia abajo
imagínate que tras todos estos puntos y
te quedaría una función que es cóncava
y si ahora subo de nuevo esta pantalla
que más me dice como la tendencia de los
datos es decreciente y cóncava encuentro
un modelo exponencial decreciente con
carbón y un modelo cuadrática
decreciente cóncavo cuales las
siguientes funciones se ajustan mejor a
los datos y bueno date cuenta que aquí
tenemos las dos funciones esta función a
déjame bajar un poco la pantalla la voy
a bajar justo por aquí esta función
es una función exponencial es mi función
de verde la cual la tenemos justo aquí
es decreciente y cóncava y esta función
bem es una función de color morado la
cual es una cuadrática una cuadrática
que como tiene un signo negativo es
decreciente y cóncava ahora me preguntan
cuál de las siguientes funciones la de
verde que es exponencial es la demorada
que es la escuadra tica se ajusta mejor
a los datos y bueno si te das cuenta
ésta está demorada para cualquier tiempo
dado recuerda que el tiempo lo estamos
midiendo en meses está demorado está
subestimando los puntos que tenemos aquí
por debajo de ellos sin contar este
punto y este otro punto todos los demás
puntos están por arriba de esta función
por lo tanto esta función de morado mi
función cuadrática está subestimando
estos puntos de mi medición
ahora si te fijas en la exponencial esta
tiene más consistencia en subestimar a
veces a los puntos pero también
sobreestimarlos algunos de estos puntos
quedan abajo de ella y algunos otros
quedan arriba de ella así que te da una
mejor percepción de los puntos a
comparación de esta de morado de mi
función cuadrática la cual siempre está
subestimando a estos puntos por lo tanto
yo estoy convencido que esta función la
función a mi función exponencial es una
función que se ajusta mucho mejor a los
datos por lo tanto voy a poner a esta
como la respuesta de mi primer pregunta
después dice usa la función elegida es
decir la función exponencial para
predecir el tamaño de la población de
coyotes
con meses después del tornado redondea
tu respuesta al entero más cercano
bueno pues según mi función en cinco
meses mi función de verde que es mi
función exponencial estaría muy debajo
de 60 coyotes un poco arriba de cero
coyotes pero ya quedarán muy pocos de
ellos así que vamos a comprobarlo
recuerda que realmente lo que no está
diciendo esta función es que x
representa el tiempo el tiempo en meses
mientras que jeff ya representa la
cantidad de coyotes así que si lo
metemos ahora aquí en la calculadora que
vamos a obtener bajemos un poco esto y
quiero 550 550 a este valor le voy a
quitar 3.5 3.5 esto elevado a esto lo
voy a elevar a la cantidad de meses que
es 5 elevado a las 5 en mi respuesta me
va a dar 24
78 pero lo que hemos redondeado al
entero más cercano así que me va a dar
24 25 coyotes lo voy a poner aquí 20 5
coyotes y si ahora comprobamos nuestra
respuesta vamos a ver de lujo hasta el
próximo vídeo